says the push to get more and more
people vaccinated continues across the
country
nevada the latest state to offer an
impressive raffle and entice everyone
that may be on the fence to get their
shot
sasha loftis was there for today's
announcement over at allegion stadium
she joins us with more on what southern
nevadans have to say
brian state leaders really hope this
pushes us over that herd immunity
threshold now people we spoke with today
in the las vegas community say they
really do think it will make a
difference
and get people on board with the kovid
19 vaccine
5 million reasons to get your covit 19
vaccine vaccine nevada days is a covet
vaccine incentive promotion
that will provide 5 million dollars in
cash and prizes
nevada has joined a list of other states
offering incentives for those who get
their shots
that would definitely make people want
to come out and get vaccinated some
love the idea while others are choosing
to hold off
just waiting just to see you know the
developments
with the science nevada's vaccination
numbers are still lagging behind other
states
that's why leaders are kicking things
into high gear
with vax nevada days we need to get
shots in arms to protect people as much
as possible
anyone who's had at least one dose will
be entered into a raffle to win
cash education savings plans state park
permits and fishing licenses
one lucky person will also win a grand
prize
of one million dollars every single
nevadan counts as we work to end this
pandemic
it's an idea many call inventive in the
rush to return immunity
i would get vaccinated anyway to stay
safe and keep my kids and my family safe
but even better
if i'm getting something extra for it
and they believe it will help us
inch even closer to community-wide
protection
now this is a federally funded program
and will not impact nevada taxpayers now
the raffle is also anonymous
and no private interme information
rather will be released we of course
have more information on this
on our website 8newsnow.com reporting
live in las vegas tonight sasha loftis
8 news now